welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
hey banana morris thank you so much for
having me this is great i've been in
quarantine for a year
it is what it is i've been living with
my girl and it's been good
it's been good the universe kind of
brought us together aka covet
thank god she had her own place um
but i almost got kicked out three times
for hard eyes i had to unlearn
a lot of stuff you know sitting hard
eyes you know how hard it is to try to
convince
your girl that you and your boys just
hit hard eyes now
like babe we just sent heart eyes over
lebron that's just what we do duh you
need to get with it
i only know one person that has enjoyed
quarantine and that's my brother
my brother has really enjoyed quarantine
because he has he just came home he was
serving
five years and i only say servant
because it sounds patriotic
but he was in jail and uh he was happy
to be home it was like a regular
you know he was like all right we
unlocked but i'm out and i'm happy for
him i'm happy my brother's home
i'm happy my mom got both her sons we
all hung out
and she could just stop hyping up every
little thing
like my brother did in jail you know
she'll call me she'll go
donald's reading and he's going to
church and he's going to the gym and
she'll go
why don't you go to church it's like duh
cause i'm not in jail
my brother looks great my brother looks
great
locked up five years he's got muscles
he's got abs
clear skin it's like he was locked up in
the whole foods
i need to find like a crime that's going
to get me a one year sentence so i can
just
get abs thank you so much mitzi and
banana morris
mitzi banana mores
incredible i gotta watch that set again
let's rewind